Salut Romain... Ah t'as changé un truc toi nan ?
Oui, j'ai fait une permanente. Ouais voilà c'est ça ouais
ben pourquoi du coup ? Je trouve que ça va mieux
D'ailleurs je comprends pas pourquoi je ne suis pas né comme ça
Ah, bonne question ça
Aujourd'hui on va tester un nouveau truc, on est d'accord on se pose tous pleins de questions
genre plein de questions sur notre santé sur notre corps etc
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là et que je suis là aussi
des fois c'est complexe donc ça mérite une vidéo
des fois c'est plus futiles ou plus légers donc la réponse elle est beaucoup plus simple et du coup elle est beaucoup plus rapide
mais est ce que c'est vraiment une raison pour laisser toutes ces questions sans réponses ?
et ben moi je dis non
alors aujourd'hui on va tester un nouveau format on va partir sur quelque chose de plus court et on va juste
répondre à la simple question de romain pourquoi j'ai les cheveux raides et pas les cheveux frisés
et ce nouveau format il s'appelle:
La Question que tout le Monde se Pose
Dans la vie on n'est jamais content
je vous le dis comme je le pense nan mais c'est vrai regardez les gens qui ont les cheveux raides ils sont faire des permanentes
et les gens qui ont les cheveux bouclés ils sont faire des lissages
encore et encore et encore
Et oui parce que non seulement on choisit pas sa nature de cheveux mais en plus il n'y a aucun
moyen de la changer de façon permanente
Ok alors disons de façon durable
et justement pour comprendre pourquoi on peut pas changer de façon définitive la nature de ses cheveux
il faut comprendre pourquoi à la base on a soit les cheveux raides soit les cheveux frisés
et ça tombe bien parce que c'est justement la question de Romain
Et la réponse se trouve sous notre peau
Dans notre terme, d'abord c'est là que se trouvent les bulles de capillaires c'est-à-dire là où naissent nos cheveux
puis à travers notre épiderme dans lequel se trouvent nos follicules à l'intérieur desquels les cheveux se développent
et poussent jusqu'à la sortie
c'est une asymétrie à l'intérieur de ces deux structures qui va déterminer si nos cheveux vont pousser raides,
ondulés, frisés ou crépus
en gros en fonction de l'inclinaison du bulbe et des différents compartiments du follicule
nos cheveux se développent différemment
si tout est aligné nos cheveux poussent tout droit donc ils sont raides
mais ils se développent pas droit donc ils sortent frisés si les structures sont courbées
ok mais pourquoi nos bulbes et nos follicules sont soit droit soit courbés ?
eh bah c'est à 85 voire 95% héréditaire
et le gène en cause s'appelle le TCHH
le TCHH son boulot c'est de coder la trichohlyaline qui est la protéine principale de la structure de nos follicules pileux
d'ailleurs le TCHH c'est l'un des trois gènes dont la mutation est en cause dans une maladie qui s'appelle
le syndrome des cheveux incoiffables
et là on parle pas de mes trois épis quand je me lève le matin on parle d'un vrai syndrome
c'est une dysplasie rare du cuir chevelu c'est à dire une anomalie de son développement
avec des signes comme : des cheveux qui deviennent progressivement couleur paille
très sec, très raides, très souvent dressés sur la tête et impossibles à domestiquer
ça commence dans l'enfance et ça s’arrange généralement tout seul en grandissant
donc on a compris la nature de nos cheveux elle dépend de facteurs
génétiques et structurels donc des trucs qui sont très profondément ancrés en nous
mais alors du coup vous savez il y a des gens qui ont les cheveux bouclés quand ils sont petits
et qui deviennent raides en grandissant
alors pas tout le monde mais des fois ça arrive
ou l'inverse d'ailleurs des gens qui ont les cheveux raides qui bouclent en grandissant
mais comment c'est possible ?
et bien la réponse à ce mystère c'est que ...
...
C'est un mystère
il y a plein d'hypothèses différentes mais rien n'a été démontré avec certitude
y en a qui parlent de renouvellement des follicules y en a qui mettent en cause des hormones
et y en a qui partent dans des histoires de chimie du cheveu
ah oui parce que ce qu'on sait par contre c'est que nos cheveux ont une structure chimique assez espiègle
nos cheveux ils sont formés de protéines de kératine qui sont liées entre elles de différentes façons
et la façon dont ces protéines sont liées entre elles peut être modifiée en fonction
du taux d'hydrogène dans l'air, ce qui modifie leur structure et donc leur forme mais de façon temporaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle certaines personnes ont les cheveux qui frisent quand il pleut
ou quand l'air est humide c'est à dire chargé en hydrogène
voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que ce nouveau format vous a plu
dites-nous ça dans les commentaires comme ça on voit si on remet ça ou si on laisse tomber
d'ici là je vous en conjure
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien !